それから サティ ヨ ヴェー
キンチッ カンメカ カンタシン
ワジェ タンジャナン カンタ
キンチッ クマ ディティ
ダンガンに合わせが置いていっている
このシンハラ語訳した人は誰ですかね
今日は 文句言ったきりじゃないんで
これはこの沙弥たちのお坊さんたちの学校で使うテキストなんです
だからシンハラ語通訳ありますけど
パーリ語とほぼ同じに難しいんです
[笑い]パーリ語でわかっても
私もシンハラ語の文ではない
[笑い]まあ子供いじめだと思います
まあ子供たちは美しいシンハラ語を学んでほしいっていうことでしょうね
それで この人々もまあもう何かもう
まあ修行を得ようかとか
何かものを得ようかといって
あちこち行ったり来たりする
で まあ旅に出たりする
今の日本ではちょっと考えられないかもしれませんですけど
まあいろいろどこか行くと
まあちょっとお接待することがあったりして
何か仕事ないのかといったら
ありますと じゃあちょっとこれで助けてくれと言ったら
それで助けたり いくらかお金かご飯かもらったりとかね
そういう風に普通に人々はまあ旅を
旅する人々はいる だから見る限りわかるんです
そういう人々は 何かちょこちょこっと仕事させてみるんだと
だからまあほんの軽い
なんとかお手伝いする
例えば歩きながら そこら辺田んぼをみんな耕しているところだったら
何か私にはやることないのかと
じゃあいいよ ちょっと助けてください
協力してください それで一日そちらで仕事をして
その何かもうご飯をもらって
何かお金をもらって また出ていくという感じで
あるいは何もそういう仕事も何もなかったら
何のことなく誰かの家に行って
今日はご飯食べてないんですけど
一日よと 別にもう見たらわかりますからね
それだったらある程度あげる
あれは何であなたそんなものをよくするんだと
いえ 何か仕事あったらやってあげましょうと言ったりする場合もあるしね
まあそういうふうな人々はいるんですよ
まあまあ それも一つの当時の社会のね
まあ一部の人間の生活でしょう
そういう人々は見るともういじめやすいんですよ
こっち来なさいって言ったら来るんだから
あるいは呼ばなくてもその人家帰れるんだから
まあ乞食と似ていますけど
乞食ではないんです 乞食は何も仕事をしないでご飯もらう
こういう人々は頼んだら仕事してあげる
頼まなかったらご飯だけもらって帰る
だから乞食ではないんです
乞食にまあ微妙に近い
ちなみに乞食よりはいじめやすいんです
だって呼んだら来るでしょうに
話したら話すでしょうに
そこでそういう人々を呼んで
あれこれと喋って喋って
もうぐちゃぐちゃいじめる
お前仕事をしろと言ったっても
本当は泥棒やってるでしょとかね
そういう家を調べていって
人のものを盗るでしょうと
言ったらその人泥棒じゃないんだからね
ものすごい嫌な気持ちになるし
そんな話言っちゃうと
本人には次の家に行けなくなっちゃうしね
だからものすごいそこ侮辱なんですよ
そう言われることはね
こっちにはあんたにやるものないんだから出て行ってくださいと言ったら
それで話終わりですからね
そうやって時間かけて
その人をいろいろ喋っていじめて
それで何もあげない そういうわけであんたは何もあげませんよと
出て行けと だから散々クタクタいじめられた後
最後にご飯もちょこっともくれないで追い出すと
その人々はものすごい惨めな人生だから
喧嘩することもできないし
反論することもできない
自分にその立場がないんだから
そんな村の人でもないでしょうし
旅人たちだから 村の人にそんなこと言ったらね
どうなるかわかりませんけどね
それはもう親戚もないし
村から村へ旅するんですよ
だから怒鳴られてもまあ許しがないんです
すごい惨めな生き方なんです
なのに一日その人をいじめて何もあげないということは
もうものすごい恐ろしいこと
これは今もう日本ではそこはちょっと想像できないんですけど
インドではそういうことは
皿にあったでしょう だからお釈迦様がそういう連中はもう諦めなさいと
わさらであって不可思議
人狼 不可思議なんだよと
それからよあったへとかれへとだねへとてようなろう
サッキプットムサーブーティタンジャニャワサローティ
自分のためであろうか
他の人のためであろうか
あるいはお金のためであろうか
目的は何であろうとも証言頼まれた時
嘘を言うならば 証言しなく行っちゃうと
本当のこと言っちゃうと自分が立場がまずい
それで嘘をつく あるいは自分の親戚や友達のために証言しなく言うんだからね
やっぱりその連中にも悪いと思って
あるいは嘘を言った方が私に金が入ると思う
だいたい証言頼むと 現代までそれありますよ
あんたこういう風に証言するならば
あんたにお金あげますよと
裏で日本でもあります
誰も真実を語らないでしょ
裁判で だから僕はそれはすっごく大変な問題で
証言っていうのはとても大事なことで
証言台に立って嘘を言う人はもう人間じゃないんだと
だから仏教では自分のためであろうとも
家族のために 友達のためであろうと
あるいは自分で裏金が入るんだからと
いくら理由があっても
証言頼んだら立ったら本当のことを言いなさい
それって人間だよ だって証言して本当かないか調べるのは人間の文化的なことでしょうに
この人盗んだかないか
税金ごまかしたかないかということは知りたいでしょうに
例えば あの まあ税金なんて言いますか
収入をごまかしたと報告しなかったと
というと 税務署でもう逮捕したりする
別に税務署はその人に対して恨みも憎しみもあるわけじゃないでしょうに
もう申告を見たらちょっと合わない
申告ものがあるんじゃないかなと
それをその人がいえ そんなことないと言っちゃうと
調べて逮捕したりもする
それから証言頼む場合は
この人は有罪か無罪か知りたいだけのことでしょうに
有罪ならばそれに適切な罰を与えるし
無罪ならばもう自由にしてあげるし
その場合嘘をつくならばね
社会なりたじゃないんですよ
だから社会なりたじゃないことをずっとやってますね
世界では 仏教ではそれも人間じゃないんだと
もう 証言台に立って嘘をつく人は
窃盗であろうと 次に よんやーていねんはさかなんわ
親戚の家に訪ねて あるいは友達の家
知り合いの家に行って
だーれすぱてびっせふりんをやって
まあ知ってる人々だからね
まあ自由に出入りできるでしょう
親戚関係の人々だったら別に
なんであの人をあんた呼んだんでしょうかと奥さんに怒鳴ることできるでしょうに
[笑い]それから友達の家に行ったりしてね
友達の家に行ってもうそれで友達が後から親にことごとく恨み 「
なんであんた男を家に呼ぶ？」 「
あんたの友達でしょ」と言うんだから
これはもう夫に対しても反論も何もできん
それでもいろいろ不倫をすると
それってもう人間差し柄んと
あるいは強引に暴力で女を犯すと
そういう人はもう人間の社会の一員として認められないと
次に よう回ったら回ってたら
母親父親 自分のかんがてよればな
年取ったところで老いたところで体力がなくなったところで
守さんと 自分が豊かなのに
面倒見ないならば 自分も貧乏で食べるものはないし
子供にも食べさせるものはないぐらいは親にも食べさせるものがないんだから
それは親孝行していないという話にはなりません
自分には結構財産があって
ちゃんと贅沢に食べている
しかし 年老いた親を追い出す
親の面倒見ないならば
もう人間じゃありませんと
それからよう回ったら回ってたら
自分の母親 父親 それから兄弟
男の兄弟 女の兄弟 あるいはまあ親のおじさん
おばさんたちの兄弟に対してものすごい侮辱したり
怒鳴ったり 怒ったりという
悪語 悪語と呼ぶんですか？粗悪語というかね
そういうものを食ったりするならば
もう人間 文化人じゃないんだよ
いわゆるすごい丁寧な優しい敬語を使わなければいけないのです
目上の手札であっても
それが仏教文化ですと
我々は敬語使いますよ
家の中で 喧嘩する時も敬語で喧嘩します
もう兄とも喧嘩するし
姉とも喧嘩はするんですけど
兄弟だからむちゃくちゃ
喧嘩する時でもこの野郎とは言いません
お前ちゃんは殺してやるぞとは言います
この野郎殺してやるぞっていうこの野郎っていうところは
怒った兄貴も弟に使う言葉ありますからね
それをずっと使うんです
母親とも喧嘩しますけど
喧嘩しながらお母様という言葉は必ずあるんです
日本でよくお前とかもう我々信じられない
もう我々にとってはもう口から出ません
それからもうお母さんと喧嘩して何かもう目立ちることだからね
だからいくら喧嘩しながらなですったってもくださいというね
ちょうだいという その言語的にもそういうふうにできているんです
たまに出来の悪い家族ではね
声とかいうことを聞いたことありますが
こういう人々として もう我々の育ちとは違いますよ
すごく気持ち悪くなるので
だから単語ですぐ家柄わかりますよ
使ってる言語で簡単にわかります
俺に対してなんかあんたお前とかそういう言葉使うんだったら
もう育ちが良くない 私は偉いけども
仕えることをさせません
身代も出ません まあそういうことで
そういうね 家族同士で目上の人々にいつでも敬語を使う
使うべきだよということで
それを使わなかったらね
敬語ではなくて 軽視的な軽蔑的な単語を使うならば
もう人間がありませんというところで
それからようあったんプチとさんとあなたマヌサあって人々っていうのはいろいろアドバイス
アドバイスを聞くんですよ
世の中だと これはどうすればよろしいでしょうかと
学校でも先輩に後輩はどうすればいいの？どうすればいいかと聞いたりする
で こちらに初めて来た人はどういうふうにすればいいかという
そのアドバイスをしなくちゃあかんですよ
それなく社会に成り立たない
それでどうすればいいかというと
とんでもないことを言うならばやってはいけないこと
もうもう人間じゃありませんと
あるいはわかりにくく
なんか隠れ隠すという
相手になかなか分からないこと
誤解してしまったり 別にとんでもないことを言っているわけじゃないんです
なんか理解できないように隠している
それもダメだと だからそこでも社会が平和で幸せに生きるために必要な一つなんですね
誰でも誰かに悪態する羽目になります
こういう風にしましょうと
こういうやり方だよということは
人間が社会の偉い人だけ悪態するということじゃないんです
我々人間の社会で生きているんだから
もう誰が誰かに悪態する羽目になるかということもわからないんです
例えば信号のことを知らない人に対してはね
まあ信号が変わって色変わったら
もうあれば左変わったら渡りなさいと言っちゃうと
もう隠した悪態でしょう
正しい言い方じゃないでしょう
それでその人はもう赤になって渡ったらどうしますかね
それをきちんと教えてあげなければいけないんです
次にヨウカッタはパワータタンカンマン
悪を犯して罪を犯してマーマンジャンヤーティッチャティ
これは誰にもバレないようにするそうと企む
ヨウパティッチャンナカンマンと
だから罪を犯しているのに誰にもバレてない
すごい見え張って生活するならば
もうその人はもうどかしょこめんなよ
社会人でありません で
罪を犯すということを仏教ですぐ言いなさいと
私は謝ってこういうことをしましたから申し訳ありません
その方が社会としてすごく楽なんですよ
悪いことしても すぐそれは暴露するならば
何人が悪いことしますね
犯罪がほとんどなくなるんですね
たまに喧嘩になってどうしようもなくなって
人を殴ったり殺したりしたっていうのは
本当にこういうことになってしまって
私がやりましたと言うと
まあそれなりにその人は助かるでしょうしね
だから悪いことをしたら
ちゃんとそれは言うこと
謝ること 懺悔することだって
それを死なで隠すならば
もう人間じゃないんだと
次にヨーウェイパラコランガッタブッターンスティボージャナアガタナパティポージエティパンダニャワタ
それからどこかへ出て行って
人の家に それでごちそうになって
またその人々の知り合いだから
またやがて自分の家に来る
自分の家に来たら 毎日ご馳走がいいだろう
[笑い]それだったらもう人間ではないんだと
それでヨ・ブラフマナンワ・サマナンワ・アンニャンワアピ・ワニットワカン・ムサワーデーナ・ワンチェ・タンジャニャ・ワサロウィティ
これで宗教家のことを言うんですね
それからブラフマナ入りますけど
バラモンかシャマンか
だいたいこの托鉢でご飯もらって生活するバラモンたちも難民たちもお釈迦様時代ってほとんどバラモン人でしたからね
それで托鉢して生活してる人もいました
それからサマン 転倒者
それからアンニャンワアピ・ワニットワカン
また宗教家ではないんだけど
まあちょっと歌ってあげて
踊ってあげて ちょこちょことインチキくさい占いしてあげたりして
あの 何か食べてる人々もいるんですね
そういう人々は家を訪ねてくる
で その時は嘘をで騙すなかじゃ
それもおかしなことですから
簡単にまだ向こうに反論できる立場じゃないんですね
まあ何回お釈迦様にあったことだってありますけど
お食事にはお供えするそうと思って
何も用意しないで お釈迦様をひどい目に遭わせようという
出来事一つあったんです
まあご馳走を用意して食べさせないというね
まあその時はね まああまり問題起きなかったんですけどね
お釈迦様はやることはないんだからね
それから次にバラモン人かシャモンかっていう場合は
どっちも宗教家たちなんですね
出家の人々ですね 出家の人々はバッタカーでうばっていて
自分たち食事をする食事の時間で托鉢に行って人の家の前に立ってるんですね
その時は怒鳴って言いたい放題のことを
侮辱の言葉で怒鳴って
ご飯一皿でもあげないと
あげないならばあげないでいいんですけど
怒鳴る必要はないんです
侮辱 けなす必要はないんです
それはもう人間のやることじゃないんだと
それから頭が悪くて モホですね
無知で もうぐちゃぐちゃ真理ではなく
もういろんなことを言うと
あれは霊能者みたいにね
もうオーラ見るとあれやこれや食べてるんだからね
被害をいろいろ騙してね
それでキンチック・ニジキーンさん何か欲しいんですよと
そのテレビのグループはかなり強烈なひどいグループでしたけどね
互いに喧嘩するんです
一人が過去生が見えるなんて
あなたは過去に犬でしたよとか
もう一人は自分にも人の過去生が見えるんだよとかね
それでああでこうで もう無茶苦茶嘘っていうかバレバレなんですけど
言ってる過去生っていうのは
それで聞く側がそういえばそうでしたよとね
大体人間での過去生は褒めてあげちゃうとそうでしたと思っちゃうんです
だから過去生言うのは簡単です
すごい簡単でぴったし当たります
まあ男ならあんたは昔侍でしたとかね
あんた昔あんたのところにもけはいというかね
使用人とかで人ぐらいいたんじゃないですかね
だから今も情緒的で何のことなく人にあれこれと言ってるでしょ
言うと気分がすごくいいんです
そういえば自分が何のへっちゃらでいるとこだけのはこれやってあれやってるけどって
あれかもしれない どんな人間もそういうことやりますからね
決まってます 占い師見てください
女が一番気分が調子に乗るのは何言われて喜ぶか一言とかね
過去生占うとそういうふうになってくるんで
過去生で犬でしたと言っちゃうとね
そう言ってはいけませんと一人が怒って
我々の言葉で人は死にましょうと
まあそれが人間精神的にね
もう末期状態は結構ですからね
もう言われたらもう自殺する可能性もありますからね
過去生でゴキブリでしたよと言われちゃうとね
そういうふうな とにかく
そういう人々はそれで食べているでしょう
仏教から見ればもうすっごく人間らしくない職業なんですね
そんなもの食べていたければ
もうもうガソリンスタンドで
もう何と言いますか 労働したってもよろしいし
あの宅急便屋さんに行って荷物運ぶ仕事したってもよろしいし
何でもいいでしょうに
品格のある仕事ですからね
あるいはどこか田舎に行ってね
田舎で農業やってるみんなおじいさん
おばあさんたちでしょ
若者は何のことなく そこでおじいさん
もうあの手伝わせてくださいと
いや 向こうも喜んでね
いいよと言ってね 手伝ってもらうでしょうに
それでおじいさんからご飯やら野菜やらいろいろ金やごちそうもらったっていうのは
それはすごい品格のある仕事でしょう
人を騙してないでしょう
だからそういう風にも頭が悪い
悪くもうありもない ありもしないものをいろいろ言ったりして
なんとかもらうっていうことは
まあ人間らしくない仕事だと思う
ヨーチャッターナ サムッカンゼー パランチュモージャンヌティ
自分をすごく褒め称えて
他人のことをけなすならば
もう高慢で惨めな人間だよ
あまり高慢でね 仏教から見るとすごい惨めな人ということ
で とにかく自分のことならすごくもうもうすごい褒めてんの
自分がすごい偉い 人の何それぐらいのことはとかね
そういう風に人のことをけなしてみる性格だったら
また人間らしくないんだと
で 他人に怒鳴る 怒る ものすごいケチ
それからもう考え方がすごく気持ち悪い思考を持っている
まっせり もう同じなんですけど
まあもうケチというかね
何も人にあげないとかね
またもうずる賢い 何の恥も知らない
何の道徳を侵すことに何の怖さも感じない
道徳を侵すことに何の恥も感じない人間というのは
まあ人間じゃないな それからヨブッダン パリバーサティ
釈尊を冒涜するならば
ブッダをね 釈尊ではなくて
ブッダを冒涜するならば
あるいはブッディスタを冒涜するならば
それからパリッパージャン
あのただ漁業して修行する人々いるんですね
本当に真面目に 別に仏教ということでもないんですけど
そういう人々を冒涜するならばね
あるいは佐伯な人であることね
仏教の人々 仏教を信仰している人を馬鹿にしたり
冒涜した人ならば その人々も
人間の社会に迷惑だよと
だから社会人として罪を背負うという
まあ罪を背負うということが私が入れる間違いの単語で
いわゆるヴァサラですよ
で あの仏教はものすごい世界に唯一な信じ方っているし
で 唯一な平和な教えでしょうし
すべての人類に普遍的に信じ方っているでしょうし
何の差別もない教えでしょう
だから世の中にある一切戦争であろうが
政治の問題であろうが
社会問題であろうが 家族の問題であろうが
経済的な問題であろうが
ブッダの教えからでないと解決はしないんです
みんなの言い方では全部ダメで実がないんです
ですから 仏教を侮辱する人はならん
いくら自分が信じていないと思っても
それがもう人類に対する迷惑なんです
だから たとえ最近の仏教徒であろうとも
しっかり言っているんです
みんなに模範になるように
お前腰抜けではないかとか
変な宗教だからあんた嘘つかないでしょとかね
そんなこと言うと 真理を語って真面目にいる人ということっていうのは
まあかっこ悪いと他の人と思っちゃうんですね
だからみんな欲に引きするんだからね
それはものすごい大変なことで
みんなの力になって それから呼びアナハラアナハラ阿羅漢と
悟ってもないのに 私は悟っているんだと
阿羅漢になってないのに
私は阿羅漢であると言うと
その人は宗教の泥棒だよと
ものすごい一番恐ろしい泥棒
で 私が阿羅漢になって私が悟ってるけど
みんなそちらに行くでしょ
その人本当は嘘言っているんです
それでその人の話に行くでしょ
誰にも悟れないです 誰も悟らないでしょ
しかし 信徒の人みんな真面目なんですけど
あんたが悟ってるんだったら
やっぱり私が取りたいということになりますからね
だからそれだけはもう嘘の中で一番大きな嘘です
出家している人はそれ言ったらそれで出家もちゃらになっちゃう
それだけで 人類に対して多大な迷惑であって
多大な損なんです それで終わり
その説法は もう人間形だけ人間で人間でない
ものは何なのかと このバラモンに教えてあげたんです
かなり痛い 耳が痛かっただろうと思います
本人やっていることをどうどうと
で あなたそうやっているでしょとは言わない
ではなくて すごく普遍的に世の中ではこういうことをやるならば
まあそれは間違っている教えだ
誰にも言わないでしょ
だって人類にとって一番大事なことを語っていますからね
それで次に結論出しますよ
エーテーコーワサラルッタ
マヤウォーディーパカーシタ
それで私は君にワサラになること
方法を教えてやりましたと
全部 完璧に 完結してなる
それ以上教えるものはないと思います
お釈迦様はベストだから
これで以上も以下もないんだろうと
こういう性格だったら
もう人間 社会人じゃありませんと
ナジャッチャーワサローホーティー
生まれではワサラになりませんと
ナジャッチャーが生まれでブラモンにもなりませんよと
カースト制度は一撃で否定したんです
母親の家柄どうでもいいんだよ
そんなのは あなたの生き方によって
あなたは偉いブラモンという優れた人になるか
不可触民族になるかはあなたの生き方次第だと
ということで 仏教ではこの家柄が何やってことは全然気にしない
立派な家で生まれたってのも
だらしない人はだらしないと
道徳ない人はもうとんでもない人間だと
カンマナワサローホーティー
カンマナホーティーバーフマ
行為によって不可触民になるし
ブラフマンにはなりません
聖者にもなりません 行為によって聖者にもなりません
それから 例を出すんです
これは事実であることに
あなたには例として教えてあげますよと
タダミナーテートリジャーナートヤッターメーダンニダッスナ
それで例を言いますよと
チャンダラプット・ソーパーコ・マータンゴ・イティ・イッスート
アンタカト知ってるんですよ
アンタカトの伝統の中でマータンガという名前の人が
その人はチャンダラプットという
チャンダラっていうのはまたこのワラと同じすっごい低いカーストの人なんで
いわゆるこの便所を掃除する
ものすごい低い か狩りをやるか
どちらかの仕事 人がいたんだよと昔
ソーヤサン・パラマンパット・マータンゴヤン・スドゥッラヴァン
その人は人類の中で偉大な仙人になりましたよと
彼がもうあまりにも社会から侮辱されて
もう離檀されて嫌になっちゃって
森に入って修行したんです
瞑想したんです それで仙人になったんです
禅定覚って それでいろいろことを行ったみたい
彼に尊敬するために カッティア
シャ トレ シャ あの大きな人々のブラマン人も揃って来て
彼を礼を拝んだんじゃないのかと
でも生まれは一番チャンダラというカーストでしたよと
で この人の一生の中で
こちら書いてないんですけど
なんかあの 彼が人相もありましたからね
どこかの家に行って何かご飯もらおうといっても
けなされちゃったんで
もう入るなよと 不可触民そこはと
で 出ていったんとその瞬間に家のみんななんか発作起こして体にじ曲がっちゃってもう動けなくなっちゃった
ブラマンの人々でしたけどね
それで これすごい修行者だからね
それでみんな怖くなって
何やっても治らない 発作起こしちゃって
もう口からもう なんていますか
痰ぐっぱい出して 目がもう突いちゃって
もう どうしようどうしようと
そしたらなんでそうなったのかと調べると
ある仙人を侮辱したっていうことがあって
その人を探しに行ったんです
それがこれマータンガなんですよ
別に私は何もしてないっていうことを
人にする 悪事するわけじゃないんだからね
もう仙人だからね しかしこうなってますよと
ああ そういえば 私の家柄
私も不可触民族だからね
生まれ 生まれは 私は何か言われた覚えありますよと
ですからどうか許してあげてくださいと
言ったら うん そうですね
まあ私は 私も食べ残しありますよ
この食べ残しをね 水に溶けて
溶かして みんなに頭からか
かぶってあげるから やっぱりわざとこの人の食べ残しは食べない
我々インド文化圏の人々は
母親が残したらもう残さなくても奪って食べますけどね
父親がもらうのはそれはすごくもうえらい好きなんです
私も小さい時はやっぱり母親食べてる時に食べてるのに
なんとなく近寄るんです
だからほんのちょこっとくれますからね
これが一番自分食べたものよりすごく美味しい
で また父親からもうちょっと一口をもらったりする
それはものすごく美味しいんですけど
それ以外は食べないです
親戚同士でもだってば
まあまあ 自分の母親のね
上の兄弟二人 おばさん二人もあったから
だから母親より上だから
まあ尊敬しなくちゃいけないんですね
その二人がご飯作っていろいろ食べられたりしたって
それは別にあんまり抵抗は感じないんですけど
僕はそれをよく感じるんです
これは文化だと思いますけどね
食べて残ったものは食べない
しかし だからわざとこの比丘たちはね
一人の坊さんが食べて残ったものあったら
これは食べなさいと 食べない
まあ必要だったらそれを食べてもよろしいと
そういうことは仏教の出家世界では一応一つ決まりとしてあります
それってお釈迦さんの決まりだから全然不思議で
まあ誰か長老がね 自分食べてるものに
じゃああんた食べなさいと言われても全然違和感感じません
今もそれすっごく拒絶反応起こるんですよ
偉い誰か長老とかね これだから全然もう何のこともないんで
何に違和感もなく 拒絶反応もなく
もう食べたりはする それは出家同士で
それでそこで普通の友達同士ではやらないことを友達でももうもうもう知恵分けてるような感じで
友達だったらそれの証明として一緒にご飯食べる
同じ皿に分けて二人で
これっていうのはもうものすごい友人ということなんで
兄弟よりも絆がもうすごい固いということで
まあ日本でもあれなんとか酒飲んでるでしょ
同じものでやれなんてあったね
あれってそういう絆作ることなんですよ
同じ なんで酒で結婚するときは
え？え？酒で同じもので飲むでしょ
二人とも同じでもので
それもお互い二人ではなくて
まあすごい固い絆がもう作られたんだということなんですよ
だからそんなに珍しい変な習慣ということじゃないんです
日本にもあります 違うところはこちらで酒飲むだけ
向こうだったらそれはご飯にそえるんです
ヒンドゥー教では旦那さんがこのミルク入れてるお祭り炊くご飯を作って
それを祝福のお祝いの食べ物なの
それは人一口を自分で食べて
一口を奥さんに食べさせる
で 奥さんも一口食べて
また同じ皿から一口を旦那に食べさせる
それで結婚が成立する
それ以外はやりませんと
人のものは食べません
変わったもの そういうところはえらい厳しいというかね
別に論ではないんですよ
人間の習慣にはね それだから友達同士でならないことで
このマハサンガさんが不可触民族の人なんです
病気に倒れたのはバラモン人なんです
食べ残しっていうのは一番不浄なものなんです
そこは洗っちゃうとさらに不浄だと感じるんです
洗ったもの それは大人だからかぶりなさい
かぶったってしょうがないでしょ
そのままだと死んじゃいますからね
かぶった途端 たちまち病気が治まったと
それで人のカースト見て侮辱するんじゃないんだよと
命を助かってもらったんだからね
それですごい人だと分かって
尊敬することになったんだ
それでこの梵天の神様
梵天神々たくさんいるんですけどね
なんか時々彼に会いに来てみたいんですね
それも何回もあって それを見ていて
だからこの聖者の一人として
聖人の一人として インド文化で
バラモン文化でよく知られているエピソードなんです
お釈迦様はそれをどうどうとスカウト
仏教の物語の1話になってます
だからそのエピソードに言われているでしょう
カレーニワソーデーヴァラーナム
デーヴァヤーナマーリヒャ・ヴィラジャンソー・マハパタン
カーマラーガン・ヴィラジト・ブラフマローク・パゴアフ
彼が亡くなった時はみんなに見えるように天に上がっていったんです
梵天に 死体を置いておいて
だから派手に宣伝したんですよ
その方は それは素晴らしいことで
みんな人間平等だよと
頑張りなさいよと 行為よ
行為だよと 生まれじゃないんだよということをね
それでお釈迦様が言うのはナナン・ジャータ・ニワーレーシ・ブラフマローカ・ウパッティヤ
梵天に生まれる生まれ変わるためには
カレーニ 生まれは邪魔にならなかったと
ブラフマン教では梵天に生まれたいということでしょう
でもあなた方 生まれによって人が聖者になると言ったってもね
あの人には梵天に行くことには何の邪魔もなかったでしょうと
アッジャヤト・クレー・ジャータ・ブラフマナ・マント・バンダナ
それでテーチャ・パーティ・ス・カンネ・カテーバ・アッジャヤト・クレー・ジャータ
あのヴェーダ聖典唱え唱え
毎日唱えて毎朝毎晩昼も唱えて
法摩やったり護摩焚いたり
もうやってるこのヴィジェのね
二回生まれたブラフマン人であろうとも
ヴェーダ聖典は他の人には唱えてはいけないということを自分たちだけ唱えている
しかし 彼らが悪を犯したりして悪人たちと絡み合っている場合はね
ディッティョ・ダンメー・カーリヤ
この世の中でみんな非難しますよと
バラモン人だと思ってないんだと
だからこれ社会の事実であって
あの人泥棒ですけど バラモン人だからしょうがないでしょうとは言わないんですよ
泥棒は泥棒扱いするんだから
不倫やってるんだったらバラモン人だからどうそう
どうそうと ないんだからね
だからこの世の中でも非難されますよ
死んじゃったら地獄に行きますよと
生まれはできませんよと
ですから 生まれによって人は尊いものにもならないし
卑しいものにもなりませんと
行為によって卑しい人間にもなるし
尊いものにもなるんだよということで
結論としてお釈迦様は今日終わりました
このバラモン人はどうしようもなくて仏教徒になりました
はい ありがとうございます